สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าวันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วัน
ศุกร์ไหม
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 2 ค่ะ
เดือนอะไรคะ
มิถุนายน
ค่ะ
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอ่า
วันนี้วันพฤหัสบดีค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 1
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนมิถุนายน
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2566 ปีค.ศอะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะ
พรุ่งนี้วันเสาร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 3
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนมิถุนายน
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้า
ตอนนี้เวลา
10 โมง
10 โมงกี่นาที
4 นาทีค่ะ
ครูหญิง
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยกินข้าวเช้ากี่โมง
ภูฟ้ากินข้าวเช้าตอน
8 โมง
ตกใจไหมคะนักเรียนเพราะว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ย
ปกติ 8 โมง
ครูพระนอน
อันนั้นก็คือตอนครูฟ้าอยู่ประเทศไทยใช่
ไหม
ใช่ค่ะ
แต่
อะไรคะผู้หญิง
เมื่อเช้าตอน 8 โมงแล้วค่ะตั้งแต่ครูฟ้า
มาอยู่ออสเตรเลีย
อันนี้คืออะไรคะ
อันนี้คือประเทศไทย
ครูฟ้าไม่ใช่ค่ะครูฟ้า
ตั้งแต่ครูฟ้ามาอยู่อันนี้นะออสเตรเลีย
เนี่ยนะคะ
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยกินข้าวเช้าตอน 8 โมง
ใช่ไหมคะครูฟ้าอยู่ประเทศไทยเนี่ยกูฟ้า
ไม่เคยกินข้าวเช้าเลยใช่ค่ะนักเรียน
Amazing ไหมคะฟังไม่เคยกินข้าวเช้าเลย
เพราะว่าครูฟ้าไม่ตื่น
เพราะว่า 8 โมง
แล้วครูฟ้าตื่นกี่โมงล่ะตอนครูฟ้าอยู่
ประเทศไทยอ่ะเลยไม่ได้กินข้าวเช้าตอนครู
ฟ้าอยู่ประเทศไทยเนี่ยครูฟ้าตื่น
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยตื่นขึ้นมากินข้าวมันก็ไม่ใช่
ข้าวเช้าแล้วไงเพราะว่าเวลาเที่ยงเนี่ย
ไม่ใช่ตอนเช้ามันเป็นตอนกลางวัน
เพราะฉะนั้นครูฟ้า
มาออสเตรเลียเนี่ยไม่ใช่สิครูฟ้ามา
ออสเตรเลียครูฟ้าก็เลยได้กินข้าวเช้าแล้ว
นะคะหรือว่าอาหารเช้าก็ได้ข้าวเช้าอาหาร
เช้า
นักเรียนนักเรียน comment ปรบมือ
สติ๊กเกอร์ปรบมือดีมากครูฟ้ากินข้าวเช้า
แล้วครูฟ้ามาออสเตรเลียเนี่ยครูฟ้ากิน
ข้าวเช้าที่บ้านหรือว่ากินข้าวเช้าเขา
เรียกอะไรนะ
ไปซื้อข้างนอกบ้าน
กินข้าวที่บ้านหรือกินข้าวข้างนอกใช่ไหม
ตอนเช้าเนี่ย
แน่นอนค่ะว่าครูฟ้ากินข้าว
ที่บ้าน
ข้างนอก
ก็คือตื่นนอนมาอาบน้ำแล้วก็ไปเรียนใช่ไหม
ก่อนไปเรียนก็คือเงินแล้วก็ไปซื้อข้าว
เช้า
อันนี้อะไรคะ
อ๋ออันนี้ไปเรียนค่ะ
อันนี้คือถนนหรอ
อันนี้ที่โรงเรียนของฟ้านะคะ
ตัว C ใหญ่ๆเขาเรียกว่าอะไรไม่รู้แต่ภาษา
อังกฤษคือ college ก็โรงเรียนแหละเนาะคน
ไทยก็พูดโรงเรียนนะ
โรงเรียน
มันไม่ใช่ University ไงนักเรียนก็ไปโรง
เรียนนั่นแหละแล้วก็ครูฟ้าก็ไปซื้อนะคะ
เป็นอาหารเช้าเป็นข้าวเช้าของครูฟ้าอ้าว
ก็คือข้าวนะคะนักเรียน
แต่ถ้าเราไม่ได้กินข้าวเราก็พูดข้าวเช้า
ได้ไหม
ได้ๆได้เนาะคนไทยกินข้าวไงอะไรที่กินเข้า
ไปก็เป็นข้าวได้ใช่ค่ะทั้งหมดก็ข้าวเช้า
ของครูฟ้าบางทีเป็นช็อกโกแลตนะคะกับ
ช็อกโกแลตเป็นเครื่องดื่มนะคะ
เครื่องดื่มมันคือ Hot  Chocolate กับ
อาหารเช้าที่ข้าวเช้าที่ครูฟ้ากินก็คือ
แว๊บหรือว่าแฮมชีสอะไรอย่างเงี้ย
แล้วครูฟ้ากินข้าวเช้าทุกวันไหมตั้งแต่
วันจันทร์ถึงวันอาทิตย์เลยแล้วกันเนาะทุก
วันครูฟ้ากินข้าวเช้าไหมคะหรือว่า
จันทร์ถึงศุกร์ไปเรียนเนาะเพราะว่าวัน
เสาร์วันอาทิตย์เนี่ยครูฟ้าไม่ได้ไปเรียน
เนาะอาจจะแบบตื่นเที่ยงก็ได้แต่จันทร์ถึง
ศุกร์เนี่ย
ฟ้าเรียนทุกวันกินข้าวเช้าทุกวันไหมคะ
จันทร์ถึงศุกร์ครูฟ้า
กินทุกวันค่ะ
บางวันกิน Hot  Chocolate
ใช่ไหมบางวันกินซูชิ
ทำไมแต่ละวันเนี่ยกินไม่เหมือนกันล่ะคะ
เพราะว่าอันนี้คือโรงเรียนครูฟ้าใช่ไหมคะ
มันจะ
อันนี้เราบอกว่าเป็นตึกเรียนนะคะนักเรียน
ตึกก็คือสูงๆเหมือนคอนโดมิเนียมใช่ไหมสูง
ๆแล้วก็มันจะมีข้างในตึกเนี่ยมันจะมีร้าน
ซูชินะคะ
แล้วก็เป็นคาเฟ่มันก็จะมีแค่ 2 ล้าน
กินไปคาเฟ่ต์ก็ไปร้านซูชิ
มีให้เลือก a กับ B ใช่ไหมคะก็เลือก
แล้วมีวันไหน
ที่ครูฟ้ากินข้าวเช้าทุกวันไงแต่ถ้ามันจะ
มีสัก 1 วันที่ครูฟ้าคิดว่าจากบ้านแล้วก็
ครูฟ้ามาโรงเรียนแล้วก็ไม่ได้กินข้าวเช้า
เพราะครูฟ้ากินทุกวันใช่ไหมแต่ถ้ามี 1
วันที่ครูฟ้าไม่ได้กินข้าวเช้าเนี่ย
ครูฟ้าคิดว่ามันจะมีอะไรได้บ้างที่ทำให้
เราเนี่ยไม่ได้กินข้าวเช้าครูฟ้าบอกไป
แล้ว 1 ข้อตอนที่ครูฟ้าอยู่ประเทศไทย
ไม่กินข้าวเช้าเพราะว่านอนใช่ไหมยังไม่
ตื่นก็เลยไม่ได้กินข้าวเช้า
ก็เลยไม่ได้กิน
ก็คือ 1 ข้อนะคะถ้าเรานอน
เราก็จะไม่ได้กินข้าวเช้า
ก็
หนึ่งนอนใช่ไหม 2
น่าจะ
ตื่นสาย
อย่างครูฟ้าเนี่ย
กินข้าวเช้า 8 โมงเช้าทุกวัน
ทุกวันครูฟ้าก็ตื่นตั้งแต่กี่โมงอ่ะคะ
ว้าว
8 โมงแล้วเรียนกี่โมง
เรียน 9 โมงค่ะ
วันนี้ครูฟ้าเนี่ย
ไม่ได้ตื่น 7 โมงตื่น 8 โมงตื่นสาย
มีเวลาข้าวเช้าไหม
ไม่มีค่ะ
ถ้าตื่นสายก็ไม่มีเวลากินข้าว
ต้องรีบใช่ไหมก็คือตื่นสายแล้วอาจจะมี
เหตุอีกอย่างนึงก็คือรีบไง
ใช่รีบนะคะรีบก็คือทำอะไรเร็วๆฉันรีบ
ก็คือรีบนะคะเราก็เลยไม่ได้กินข้าวกับ
ตื่นสายน่าจะคล้ายๆกันตื่นสายก็ต้องรีบ
มันมาจากว่า 1 ครูฟ้าเนี่ยตื่นสายทุกวัน
ตื่น 7 โมงแต่ถ้าวันนี้จริงๆไม่ต้อง 8
โมงก็ได้นะถ้าวันนี้ครูฟ้าตื่น 7 โมง
ครึ่งก็สายแล้วพอตื่นสายสเต็ปที่ 2 เราก็
ต้องรีบไงพอรีบต้องไปเรียน 9 โมงให้ทัน
วันนี้กินข้าวเช้าไม่ได้เพราะว่ารีบไม่มี
เวลาเพราะร้านซูชิร้านคาเฟ่อาจจะมีคิวไม่
มีคนเนี่ยยืนยืนยืนยืนต่อคิวอยู่ครูฟ้า
ไม่มีเวลาแล้วอ่ะ
ไปซื้อไม่ได้หรือไม่มีเวลาทำเองด้วยนะบาง
ทีถ้ารีบมากๆ
ก็เลยไม่ได้กินอาหารเช้าไม่ได้กินข้าว
เช้า
แล้วก็สำหรับครูฟ้า 3 ข้อต่อไปนะคะข้อที่
3 อะไรคะที่ทำให้ครูฟ้าจะไม่ได้ทั้งเช้า
อะไรที่ทำให้ครูฟ้าไม่ได้กินข้าวเช้าก็
คือครูฟ้าไป
เรียนแล้ว
ร้านซูชิปิดคาเฟ่ปิด
ก็คือไม่มีอาหารขายนั่นเอง
ไม่มีอาหารขายค่ะ
ครูฟ้าจะไม่ได้กินข้าวเช้าแบบออโตเมติก
ทันที
ไม่ได้ทำอาหารเช้ากินเองครูฟ้าไม่ได้กิน
เช้าที่บ้านครูฟ้ามาซื้อข้าวเช้ากินที่
โรงเรียนใช่ไหมถ้าวันนี้คนขายซูชิปวดท้อง
ปิดร้านคนขายคาเฟ่ร้านคาเฟ่ขี้เกียจไม่
อยากเปิดกูฝันเดินมาถึงแล้ววันนี้ฉันจะ
กินซูชิหรือว่าจะกินแรปซูชิหรือว่าเดิน
เข้ามาปุ๊บ
ซูชิปิดร้านคาเฟ่ปิด
ก็ไม่ได้กินข้าวเช้า
เคยมีไหมคะครูฟ้า
ครูฟ้าไปเรียน
คาเฟ่เขาก็เปิดทุกวันซูชิเขาก็เปิดทุกวัน
ไม่มีนะ
วันที่ 25 ธันวาคม
เนี่ยถ้าเป็นวันคริสต์มาสเนี่ยเขาจะปิด
คือซูชิ
คาเฟ่ปิดโรงเรียนครูฟ้าก็ปิดเหมือนกันคือ
คู่ฟ้าก็ต้องไปเรียน
ร้านปิด
ร้านอาหารปิดไม่มีอาหารขายก็ไม่ได้กิน
อาหารเช้า
ข้อต่อไป
อะไรคะที่ทำให้เราจะไม่ได้กินข้าวเช้า
หรือว่าครูฟ้าไม่ได้กินข้าวเช้าข้อที่ 4
ปวดท้อง
ใช่ไหมนักเรียนเคยไหมคะปวดท้อง
เดี๋ยวเวลาที่ครูฟ้าปวดท้องครูหมอไม่กิน
ข้าวหรอ
ไม่กินค่ะเพราะว่าปวดท้องแล้วมันจะมีปวด
ท้องแบบพี่หนึ่งปวดท้องแบบที่ 2 ปวดท้อง
แบบที่ 3  4  5  6  7  8 มันมีปวดท้อง
เยอะๆใช่ไหม
อันนี้คือฟ้าไง
เออครูฟ้าปวดท้อง
กินข้าวไม่ได้มันปวดท้องปวดท้องท้อง
หรือว่าจะแบบ
ไม่สบายอย่างนี้เนาะ
ไม่สบายก็ไม่อยากกินอาหารเช้าแต่จริงๆ
ต้องกินนะคะ
ใช่ค่ะ
บางทีแบบทุกวันๆเห็นนะ
อยากกินแต่ถ้าวันนี้รู้สึกไม่สบาย
ปวดท้อง
อาจจะไม่อยากกินไงเพราะคิดว่าถ้ากินเข้า
ไปจะปวดท้องมากขึ้นมากขึ้นก็ไม่กินอาหาร
ปวดท้อง
มีอีกไหม
เบื่ออาหาร
ยังไงคะครูฟ้าเบื่ออาหารเนี่ย
ก็ครูฟ้าเนี่ยไปเรียน
แล้วก็เดินเข้าไปในคาเฟ่แล้วก็ช็อกโกแลต
แฮมชีสขนมปังมัฟฟินเค้กเบื่อ
ไม่อยากกินกินทุกวันเราก็จะไม่กิน
อ๋อเดินเข้าไปแล้วก็เห็นแล้ว
เมื่อวานกินแล้วแฮมชีส 2 วันที่แล้วก็กิน
มัฟฟินไม่เอาไม่อยากเบื่อใช่ไหมคะก็ไม่
อยากกิน
หรือไปร้านซูชิก็เบื่อ
ไม่อยากกิน
ก็คือแซลมอนเบื่อ
เนี่ย
ถ้าเราเบื่ออาหารเนี่ยก็คือเราเห็นอาหาร
แล้วไม่อยากกินนั่นเอง
ไม่เอาไม่เอาไม่เอาเนาะก็เบื่อ
ลบแล้วมันเคยมีไหมอ่ะถ้าวันไหนครูฟ้าเดิน
ไปเรียนตอนเช้าแล้วไม่หิว
ก็เลยไม่อยากกินอาหารเช้า
ครูฟ้าคิดว่าจะมีไหมคะ
8 โมงเช้าครูฟ้าเนี่ยเดินไปคาเฟ่เดินไป
ร้านซูชิแล้วก็
อันนี้ไม่ใช่เบื่อนะแต่ไม่หิว
ยังเพราะว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยครูฟ้าบอกว่าครู
ฟ้าหิวบ่อยๆตอนอยู่ประเทศไทยอ่ะนะตอนอยู่
ประเทศไทยนะอยู่ออสเตรเลียเอาประเทศไทย
เปลี่ยนไปหรือเปล่าคะ
ไม่เบื่อไม่เบื่ออาหารบางทีก็ไม่หิวอย่าง
วันนี้นะคะอันนี้คืออาหารเช้าของครูฟ้า
เดี๋ยวนักเรียนบอก pringle ไม่ใช่อาหารนะ
ครูฟ้าแล้วก็ m&m
คือนักเรียนปกติครูฝ้ายก็ไม่ได้กินทุกวัน
นะคะแต่ว่าวันนี้มัน
ไม่หิวเบื่อ
2 อย่างเลยเพราะไม่ค่อยหิวแล้วฟ้าก็
เบื่อซูชิเบื่อแวบเบื่อ Hot  Chocolate
แล้วเขาก็เลยกินกับ n&m's
เพราะว่าก็หิวนิดหน่อยแต่ไม่หิวมากก็เลย
กิน
ขนมนะ
เราไม่หิวแต่ไม่หิวถ้ากินแบบ
ช็อกโกแลตใช่ไหมคะ
ถ้าเราไม่หิวแล้วก็กิน Hot  Chocolate
กินแล้วเข้าไปมันจะแบบอิ่มอิ่มมากๆอิ่ม
แล้วก็นั่งเรียนเนี่ยมันไม่สบายท้องให้
ค่ะเพราะว่าที่นี่นะคะ
กินไม่หมดอ่ะมากินอาหารเช้ากับอาหาร
เที่ยง
เพราะมันแบบใหญ่
ใช่เพราะว่าสมมุติว่าอันนี้ไซส์นี้ใช่ไหม
ถ้าไซส์นี้เนี่ยแรปประเทศไทยคือแล้ว
ประเทศไทยส่วนใหญ่ก็จะใช้ประมาณนี้ไหมยาว
ประมาณนี้
ความยาวประมาณนี้แต่คิดว่าออสเตรเลียน่า
จะคูณสองไหม
ออสเตรเลียแรป 1 ชิ้น
ใช่ใหญ่ใหญ่มาก
นั่นแหละ
ถ้าวันไหนเราไม่หิวก็อาจจะไม่กินใช่ไหม
ไม่กินแบบไม่กินแร็พครูฟ้าก็อาจจะดื่มแค่
Hot  Chocolate อย่างเดียวก็พอจริงๆก็มี
อีกเหตุผลนึงนะทำไม
เราถึงไม่กินอาหารเช้า
อะไรที่ทำให้เรา
ไม่มีเงินค่ะ
ร้านซูชิเปิดคาเฟ่เปิดเราหิวมีเวลาเยอะ
อยากกินแต่ว่า
เงินไม่มี
หรืออาจจะมีเงินไม่พอเงินน้อย
ซื้อไม่ได้ก็ไม่ได้กินอาหารเช้าทำไมจบ
เศร้าอย่างนี้ล่ะคะแสบเลยจบแบบไม่มีเงิน
[เพลง]
ถ้าเป็นนักเรียนล่ะคะนักเรียนคิดว่าอะไร
ถ้าจะทำให้นักเรียนเนี่ยไม่กินอาหารเช้า
ถ้าเป็นครูหญิงเนี่ยคือผู้หญิงไม่ต้อง
ตื่นเช้าเหมือนครูฟ้าไงผู้หญิงส่วนใหญ่ก็
คือเหมือนฟ้าอยู่ประเทศไทยนะคะก็คือนอน
ยังไม่ตื่นก็เลยไม่ได้กินอาหารแล้วนัก
เรียนล่ะเป็นเพราะอะไรไม่หิว
ไม่มี
ตื่นสายรีบร้านปิดหรือเปล่าก็ comment
บอกเราได้นะคะแล้วก็วีดีโอนี้คุยกับครู
ฟ้าไปก่อนนะคะแล้วเดี๋ยวเรามาเจอกันใหม่
วีดีโอหน้านะคะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะ